Gillian is with us in Rochester New York
hi Gillian how are you hi good things
thank you for taking my call sure what's
the question
my husband isn't a teacher for 15 years
and would like to quit his job Oh God
he's been and then for 15 years he can
retire at 30 years and he would bring
home on the pension 45% of the average
of his last four years yeah but he's
gonna hate the next 15 years of his life
who would do that
all right so the question is something
uses ultimately answered it should we
stick it out no not in verse 15 months
yeah but not 15 years no we don't
worship at the altar of a bad pension
plan so what does he make fifty to fifty
two thousand okay
what's he change first education okay
what does he want to do he would love to
own his own business on the side well
he's we're trying to he doesn't really
have the time because we're we're trying
to get at that so rich working multiple
part-time jobs right his side business
makes more on his part-time job he's
accomplishing two things at once
well he wants I mean it would be to do a
food truck or open a bar a restaurant
maybe not maybe he starts with catering
which doesn't have the overhead of
either one or the upfront cost of either
one lots of the best food truck people
and lots of the best restaurants started
as a caterer out of their own kitchen
and there's no overhead and no startup
cost so he loves to cook what's he like
to cook what fried things like chicken
wings french fries you're not supposed
to do that that's a southern thing
everything down here honey oh my gosh
that's great I love it now hey start
even if he just does a side gig here or
there he doesn't have to do this quickly
it could take three years to get
business going he could make it his his
other part-time job and do fried thing
cooking at the flea market on two
weekends a month you know I don't have
to be a big thing let's just start with
something just start messing around the
business I do not recommend that you
open a bar when you've never run a bar
the failure rate among small businesses
is high the failure rate among new
restaurant owners is almost infinite
very few people make it in their very
first restaurant he's never worked in
one he's never shift
he's never operated one he doesn't know
what the crap he's doing really $50,000
in debt with an SBA loan on my house and
go open a restaurant in the neighborhood
that's dumber than dirt okay you don't
want to do that you want to learn the
craft from the inside out and have a
five-year plan of getting your your
catering business cash flowing like a
bandit and then move that into a food
truck that you pay cash for with a
proven process and recipes and proven
customers okay but if you go drop for
your 50 or 100 grand on a food truck and
you go borrow that money so he can quote
live his passion he's gonna turn his
dream into a nightmare because he
doesn't have proven recipes or customers
or processes and he doesn't know how to
operate a business yet he can learn all
of those things and I suggest he'd go do
it but it's probably a three to a five
year track that he's on to make the
conversion but quit my job and walk out
and go doing a $50,000 in debt and open
a bar oh okay so I'm with you on that
part of it because your security gland
was going off wasn't it yes yeah you
were cuz you were talking like I work 15
more years get your pension thing well
I'm going back because I thought we want
to relocate to Florida okay and I work
from home full-time so
but he can move down there he can move
down there and build his business down
there and teach down there in the mean
time so I don't care I don't five years
from today I don't want him be a teacher
anymore I want him to make $100,000 a
year operating three food trucks but I
want him to grow it to walk to get there
not dive off a diving board and hope
there's water in the pool which is what
people do all the time that have these
dreams so just don't dream let's just
take steps make it a goal turn your
dream into a goal and let's take the
clear steps to getting there
ken Holman writes about this and his
number one best-selling book the
proximity principle I'm gonna send you a
copy for your husband but this is not a
three-month ordeal here this is a three
to a five-year plan to go into the type
of business he wants to go into and
you've got to merge that with your
getting out of debt plan and your go to
Florida plan and those three things have
to kind of be woven together to create
this beautiful tapestry that we're gonna
call your life and you can do it but I
don't want him to work if he if he's if
he's you know done on teaching let's
move to the next thing there's nothing
wrong with that
hey thanks for the call